what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot has been happening with the
cast of The Fantastic Four recently if
you haven't been keeping up to date
recently it looked like our cast for The
Fantastic Four was pretty much finalized
with Adam Driver playing Reed Richards
aka Mr Fantastic Margot Robbie playing
Sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman Paul
Moscow playing Johnny Storm AKA The
Human Torch and David Diggs playing Ben
Grimm aka the thing that looked like it
was pretty much locked in with Marvel
Studios having offered contracts to play
these roles to Adam Driver and Margot
Robbie however it looks like this isn't
going to be the cast at all as we have
new reports about new actors and
actresses playing these roles right now
it looks like Sue storm is pretty much
locked down with Marvel offering the
role of Sue storm to an actress already
with some Insider stating that the role
is already set as well as stating that
the role is set for the thing and
possibly Johnny Storm as well and a
couple of these are actors who were not
in the running before their names have
not been brought up yet but of course
we're gonna break it down and tell you
everything you need to know about the
Fantastic forecast in this video and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss any of the
latest MCU news and so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X a PS4 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items we pick a winner at the
end of each month and the winner picks
one item all you gotta do is subscribe
and leave a comment down below now to
start things off like we mentioned in
our last update video it looks like Adam
Driver could be the only name from the
cast that we thought was set to still be
in the running for the Fantastic Four it
looks like Adam Driver has an outright
said no to Playing Mr Fantastic yet it
looks like they are still negotiating
and from what we've heard the problem is
money this is apparently why Margot
Robbie did not take the role as Sue
storm even though According to some
insiders it was offered to her but right
now Margot Robbie is an incredibly huge
star it doesn't really get big bigger
than her right now she is now Barbie
that movie's about to come out of course
she is Harley Quinn she's been in major
movies with Leonardo DiCaprio and Brad
Pitt et cetera Etc she's huge right now
so apparently she couldn't get the
paycheck that she wanted and because of
that it seems Marvel Studios offered the
role of Sue storm to Vanessa Kirby
Vanessa Kirby has recently become very
big due to her role in the mission
impossible franchise she was also in
Fast and Furious presents Hobbs and Shaw
and I thought that she was the best part
of that movie and I personally hope she
does play Sue storm she was my first
choice I think she'll crush it however
we have a new name to throw in for
Johnny storm today and we will get back
to talking about Mr Fantastic in just a
bit but this new name for Johnny Storm
the brother of Sue storm is Joseph Quinn
many people know him as Eddie from
stranger things apparently Joseph Quinn
is the top choice for Johnny Storm slash
the Human Torch right now over at Marvel
Studios this is coming from the dceu
mods over on Reddit they State they can
exclusively report that Vanessa Kirby is
set to play Sue storm The Invisible
Woman in the Fantastic Four and Joseph
Quinn is the top choice for Johnny Storm
now Joseph Quinn is mostly known for his
role as Eddie in stranger things we've
seen enough from him from that show to
know that he's a good actor and this
role could really help him blow up which
is what we love to see Marvel Studios do
help actors who aren't exactly huge
Stars yet become huge stars and I think
a lot of stranger things fans would like
to see Joseph in this role but go ahead
and let us know your thoughts about it
down below this is also another report
backing up the fact that Vanessa Kirby
has been offered the role of Sue storm
except this report states that she is
set to play Sue storm so it is very
possible that Vanessa Kirby has accepted
the deal to play The Invisible Woman in
the MCU this could be our Sue storm
officially but of course if we hear
anything official we'll be sure to let
you know now another one coming from the
DC ceu leaks page is that they're
reporting that Ebon Moss boxroch is set
to play the thing in the Fantastic Four
and you might recall that Ebon was
actually in the Netflix Punisher series
with John Bernthal he played David micro
so if this is true it wouldn't be his
first Marvel role it would be his first
MCU role but he has worked with Marvel
before he has also worked with lucasfilm
and Disney before he was in the Andor
series that recently came out he was in
three episodes so he has already worked
with Disney they have already been in
contact so if they wanted him to play
the thing it seems like that would be a
pretty easy deal they've worked with
them before so they know what it's like
to work with them they've obviously
enjoyed it and since he isn't a huge
name actor he could take this role as an
opportunity to get his name out there
even more he's done some great work
before but this could really Elevate his
career now some people might ask well
this is coming from DCU people but
oftentimes the contacts can be the same
and they just know things that happen at
multiple different Studios over at
Warner Brothers for DC over at Disney
for Marvel
etc etc we won't take it as official
confirmation for now but this is a
pretty big inside report so right now
our Fantastic Four cast could be Vanessa
Kirby as Sue storm The Invisible Woman
Joseph Quinn as Johnny Storm the Human
Torch and Ebon Moss boshrash as Ben
Grimm the thing and as I mentioned we'll
go back to Mr Fantastic because Adam
Driver is still in the running however
Ryan Gosling's name has been thrown out
there it's been reported by a couple of
different insiders that Ryan Gosling's
name is in the running to play Mr
Fantastic now we've also known for a bit
now that Ryan Gosling has met with
Marvel Studios and Kevin feige has even
mentioned in an interview before that he
would love for Ryan Gosling to join the
MCU and I think a lot of people would
really love that as well he is a huge
actor already he's got amazing talent
and he's been in a lot in fact right now
and this is kind of interesting he is
the co-star to Margot Robbie's Barbie he
is Ken Barbie and Ken and if they both
are or were in the running to play
members of the Fantastic Four that's
just a little coincidental considering
the fact that they're starring and
Barbie together now originally it was
reported and speculated that Ryan
Gosling originally met with Marvel
Studios to talk about plain Nova and
this very well could have been the case
perhaps at the time but we do know that
things change while doing the casting
for the Fantastic Four Marvel Studios
could have very well thought well yeah
he could be a good Nova but he could
also be a pretty good Mr Fantastic in
fact this is what Marvel Studios does
they meet with actors about possible
roles and sometimes they could meet with
them four years until they find that
perfect role it's all about finding the
perfect fit and Kevin feige has
explained this before he says they meet
with a lot of actors all the time about
possible roles that they could play but
if it's not a fit they don't do it we
actually know that Marvel Studios has
met with Keanu Reeves before yet we
haven't seen him in the MCU anywhere
hopefully it's about Ghost Rider but we
don't know but the point is they meet
with a lot of actors about a lot of
possible roles so even though Marvel
Studios might have met with Ryan Gosling
as Nova they could easily shift that
into a Mr Fantastic role so as of right
now the two people in the running for Mr
Fantastic are Ryan Gosling and Adam
Driver doesn't seem like Adam is out yet
but go ahead and let us know about the
possible fantastic forecasting in the
comments down below Adam Driver or Ryan
Gosling as Mr Fantastic Vanessa Kirby a
sue storm Joseph Quinn as the Human
Torch and a bon Moss basharaj as the
thing leave a comment leave a like and
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
you can also further support the channel
by checking out our patreon account our
website and our Discord server and of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf
me me